yeah it must be great to be Batman thank
you I'm blushing super hard under the
mask
Praeger I can only imagine he's going
home right now the party the night away
surrounded by grand and Lady activewear
models hey computer I'm home master
Bruce your greatest fear is snakes nice
clouds no it's being a part of a family
again
no now it's snake Klaus because you put
that idea in my head sir you need to
take responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising the young orphan you
adopt me I thought I was being sarcastic
hello secret camera it's the Batcave
gosh oh my gosh look at the bathtub
don't touch it the best that way don't
touch that either bad kayak forget a
costume I love it but it's Hansard just
a little tight I got an idea
it's better I can only look you in the
eyes right now I'm Batman
away come catch your greatest enemies
Superman is my greatest enemy Superman's
not a bad guy and I'd say that I don't
currently have a bad guy I am fighting a
few different people I like to fight
around hi Barbara Gordon new police
commissioner it's my dream the police
force to team up with Batman
what wouldn't that be better I hate
everything you just said nice
initialize master building here you go
nobody to that room yes we did it
pretty cool huh why did you build this
thing with only one sheet ah cuz last I
checked I only had one but let's go to
feed the Joker whoa we're going on a
family trip I can wear my costume too
well luckily for us you left your
costume back rude oh no under your
clothes that's perfect
you